some people who vape instead of smoking
those traditional cigarettes say they
deserve the right to choose flavored
products because they're legally old
enough market research shows that 22
million Americans use e-cigarettes Jenny
Janet shamlian is that a vaping shop in
Katy Texas that is just outside Houston
Janet how are adult customers they're
responding to this product that they say
could save their lives because it gets
them off regular cigarettes well Toni
there's a lot of choices in a store like
this from flavors like blueberry cobbler
to strawberry lemonade and the customers
we talked to say they want to keep those
choices this morning there is resistance
to the plan to ban some vaping products
it's a cornucopia of nicotine flavors at
the vapor trend shop in Houston at least
150 line the store shelves attracting a
steady stream of customers what
percentage of your business
is flavored e-cigarettes I'd say at
least about 60 or 70 percent but if
sales of most flavored East cigarettes
are banned manager time our so says it
could kill business they've been used to
the variety for so long that it would
definitely affect a lot of people I
don't want to smoke the flavorless stuff
so I don't think that they should get
rid of it just because they think it's
for kids you know what Stephanie says he
started raping because he wanted to quit
smoking which he started at a young age
I would rather do this then go back to
smoking cigarettes and you know died of
emphysema this one's gonna have your
standard like features to the store says
it carries products only from
established manufacturers and believes
the recent spike in serious lung
illnesses may involve people consuming
black-market products on Wednesday
authorities in Wisconsin arrested two
brothers accused of selling black market
marijuana vaping cartridges to high
school students authorities seized more
than 30 thousand vape cartridges and 57
mason jars loaded with THC oil the
active ingredient in marijuana this was
going on under our nose and if this one
is out there there's other ones out
there to give you an idea of the
popularity of flavored products a recent
survey of e-cigarette users found that
63% of them used a flavor other than
tobacco and a third
of the survey users said that they
started vaping in the first place
because of those flavours Gail or right
Janna thank you very much